uh my name is Marcus Tedesco and I lead
the engineering team at a startup called
Brink we're based here in Berlin I've
lived here since 2021 and I previously
came here from Sunny San Francisco
so what are we going to talk about today
we're going to do a brief intro to graph
database Concepts we'll talk about what
graphs are are good at and then we'll
use climate policy as an example use
case and how we have used neo4j to build
our
graph database
so what are graph databases
graph databases graphs in general are
basically the main components of them
are nodes which represent entities
usually things like nouns any type of
object people places businesses uh
policies
um
things like that and
they also have edges which are also
called relationships depending on the
type of database you use and these are
the connections between the nodes
in neo4j they also have the concept of
properties which are basically key value
pairs that are stored on both objects
like the nodes and the edges as well
uh in graph databases relationships or
edges have equal importance as nodes
and I like to think of graph databases
something like in the middle between
nosql databases and relational SQL
databases so they have relationships
between entities like tables do with
foreign keys
and many graph databases also support
indexes for faster retrieval and
constraints for import in enforcing
schemas but they are much more flexible
like a
nosql database I think technically neo4j
is considered a nosql database but it
has
a few more properties that allow it to
be used similar to how a relational
database would be used
um
graph databases have a number of
different query languages such as Cipher
Gremlin and Sparkle neo4j uses the
cipher
query language
let's do a little side by side of some
of the properties of
graph databases versus relational
databases
relational databases are much more
established whereas graph databases
still
have some maturing to do
um the community is much larger for for
graph databases and has standardized the
query language that's used with
relational databases to use some dialect
of of SQL
whereas there's not one standard across
all types of graph databases
um in terms of scalability
graphs are nice because they allow fast
retrieval even as the database grows as
long as you're querying uh
connected data elements if you're if
you're looking for random entities
throughout the whole database depending
on your query that that could be
slower but if the data is connected it's
fairly fast
um
and
with the relational databases as your
data set grows depending on what type of
query you're doing you could face
performance issues and joining multiple
tables and
um and then the last thing we're going
to compare is the visualization that I
think graph databases out of the box
provide some very interesting uh
visualization tools relational databases
can also be visualized but require
plugins to be able to do so
so what are some of the advantages of
graph databases
data modeling is very intuitive
the most of the time when you draw uh or
if you're you're doing some type of data
modeling on a new domain you end up
drawing a graph on on a whiteboard or uh
or such and these are graphs so the
there's many cases where the the real
world is naturally modeled by a graph
they're also very flexible uh it's easy
to change and evolve your schema over
time they are very efficient in querying
connected data and uh
because graph algorithms work natively
with graph databases
it's there's some very interesting
patterns that can be discovered that
might be harder to do with uh relational
databases so things like clustering
pathfinding or Community detection
um
using these algorithms you can also get
real-time insights so you could
do similarity between nodes in real time
which might be harder to do for
classification with a with a relational
database
we also use this uh we also use our
graph database
um
we query it via graphql and we use that
as our API layer
and graphs just in general play very
well with with graphql since they were
designed for graph databases
um
and and lastly the the data
visualization and the fact that the the
data models themselves can be quite
intuitive can actually keep business and
Engineering teams in sync when talking
about complex
business topics
what are some good use cases for graphs
um of course knowledge graphs it's in
the name uh social networks which many
people are aware of
um recommendation engines especially
real-time recommendation engines can
benefit from graph databases
in financial Industries fraud detection
is a big use case for graphs as well as
Supply Chain management
Transportation networks we use it for
Law and regulation which will show
shortly and communication networks as
well as things in the natural world like
molecular structures so chemistry and
biology can can be used
as well
um
what are some things to consider when
when
you are deciding whether a graph
database is right for you
data segregation does get more difficult
in a graph
um
you need to decide whether you're
logically or physically separating your
data and where in a relational uh
architecture relational database
architecture uh you may have
um either separate databases or tables
to to physically separate your data
doing so with a graph comes with some
trade-offs you
in many cases need to decide whether
you're going to use one large
interconnected graph or many small
um
essentially sub graphs or or
disconnected graphs
um
you do lose some of the advantages of of
the graph algorithms when you separate
them but if that is a requirement for
your data use case
you you can separate them into smaller
graphs
um
access access control is more difficult
when all the data is in a single graph
um so whereas you might restrict access
to certain tables to a certain
certain users or user types in a
business uh having everything in one
graph does make it a bit more
challenging there are some role-based
Access Control measures you can put in
place
but
just the nature of the the connectivity
between entities in the graph means that
access control is just a bit harder to
manage another thing to consider is
schema management as the graph gets
bigger
both one of the the positive and
negative things about having a very
flexible schema means that you can
change it and you can change it often
and
keeping track of of different versions
of
of your schema how things are connected
what type of labels you use on the nodes
and the relationships can get cumbersome
um
one of my
biggest pains right now is that there's
no concept of views in a graph database
like
neo4j
I find those very useful in a relational
database so if you rely on those heavily
uh
graph databases or at least neo4j might
not be the right solution for you they
do allow stored procedures but not in
their hosted
um
their hosted versions
graph databases uh in general are just
less mature as we discussed briefly a
minute ago
there's just fewer tools fewer
Integrations less Community Support
altogether it's more of a more Niche
there there certainly are many tools out
there many Integrations in and there is
Community Support it's just not as
robust as uh as a relational database so
if you rely on those kinds of things
heavily and want some out of the box
features or plugins and such those are
going to be fewer with graph databases
um but graph databases are excellent for
many use cases but they're not right for
all use cases
um
if you're if you're thinking about using
a graph database you may want to
consider a hybrid solution
um so you could potentially keep
uh most of your data where where it
currently resides but if you want to
model the the relationships between
large sets of data you could store a
certain amount certain pieces of
metadata in a graph and you know update
those you know daily you can keep them
in sync uh either with
um with an event based architecture and
do that in real time or you could do
batch jobs within the ETL jobs daily and
and find patterns um
on on top of the data that you already
have
um so now that we've gone over uh graphs
in general
um want to
uh briefly talk about our our use case
at bring so
um Brink is a startup
um we are building tools for companies
and private Equity to basically
understand how their business aligns
with environmental and social
sustainability goals of the EU
um so if you're from Germany and
familiar with tax fit tax fix think
about tax fix for companies for climate
and social practices regulation
we're focused on something called the
sustainable sustainable Finance
disclosure regulation which has many
different many different parts we're
going to talk about the EU taxonomy
mostly today but they also have
something called principal adverse
impacts and other many other forms of
Regulation that it references
um so why did we choose a graph database
why did we choose neo4j so
um we because we are working with
climate regulation
um we we recognize that climate
regulation is very complicated it also
is very interconnected as we'll see
shortly and it is also continually
changing so
um versioning the
different uh
kind of checkpoints of of the regulation
over time is very important that we we
know
which version you assessed your business
against
um we also are building a collaborative
platform so that companies and their
investors can work together to assess
their their business so we take
advantage of some of the social uh
some of the same features of graph
databases that social networks use
um
also neo4j comes with graphql out of the
box which was super helpful for us
um unfortunately that that is currently
a JavaScript implementation but uh still
quite useful for rapidly
prototyping new ideas uh and and trying
out new data models
um we also needed flexibility when
finding product Market fit
um our business has in our our product
has has changed over time and we wanted
to be able to quickly iterate on things
without having to for instance migrate
database schemas
all the time and and things like that
this is also a green field project since
we are a startup we we had the
opportunity to build this however we
found fit so we didn't have any of the
um the traditional kind of business
lock-in that
um some businesses might have
so uh let's dive in so we're going to do
an example of how we model the EU
taxonomy in a graph but first we need to
understand what the EU taxonomy is so
it's a classification system for
establishing a list of environmentally
sustainable economic activities so it
came into existence existence as part of
the European green deal
I it is the original version was uh 349
page document that outlined 111
different economic activities that
businesses uh assess themselves by
um in the last few months they've added
six more activities uh just as an
example of how this is this is
constantly changing
they've released this the regulation in
several different formats we just saw it
as a as a PDF they've also released it
as in this tabular form format so you
can see uh the different activities
the different activities
um descriptions about them
um also what sector they're in Nace
codes which are
economic activity classification system
that's used internationally and
[Music]
we will dive into this a little bit more
um
so they also released this as an online
tool called the EU taxonomy Compass
um as we can see here each activity
falls into a specific sector
the activity has a name and then also
the these six columns at the end are the
primary objectives of the EU taxonomy so
um these are objectives in which the
activity can contribute to so the main
objective of mitigating climate change
is is the number one objective and then
you can also assess your business
against the rest of these or excess that
specific activity against these
objectives as you can see these these
plus signs indicate that this is uh this
is an objective that this activity
um uh contributes to some of these have
uh one so these first three have one uh
have one
objective which is climate adaptation
and then we have these down here that
are of that have both mitigation and
adaptation so businesses can actually
choose which one uh or more that they
assess their business against so let's
uh click into one of these and and see
what this looks like so
um
so we're looking at one of the economic
activities that's manufacture of low
carbon Technologies for transport
so if we were whiteboarding this out it
might start out looking something like
this we have one activity
manufacturer of low carbon transport
and then as we go down this list we see
that
there's this primary one of the primary
objectives so contributing to climate
mitigation so again if we were
whiteboarding this it might look like
something like this this activity has
this objective
and then we get into uh this this
section which is the description
so this is actually a description of
this activity
as it relates to that specific objective
now
when we try to model this
um we we don't necessarily want to put
it on uh put that description on the
objective because the objective is
actually shared by many different
activities so in this case what we do is
we we create a new node that has a
description it's called Uh a match
um this the term match is is not unique
to it's not has nothing to do with graph
databases it's just what the EU taxonomy
calls the combination of an activity and
an objective is called a match so
underneath of a specific objective
so in this case mitigation there are two
main categories of criteria that you
assess your business against one is
called substantial contribution criteria
and the other is called do no
significant harm criteria so the
substantial contribution criteria
basically
um
is how you substantially contribute
positively to the the objective that
you're assessing so in this case how
does how does your business when doing
the activity of manufacture of low
carbon trans Technologies for transport
how does that positively uh contribute
to mitigation the mitigation objective
so if we model that out
it might look something like this so
you've got this this match which is the
combination of mitigation and the
manufacture of Transport activity and it
has this criteria and that criteria
contributes to the the objective so the
match and the the substantial
contribution criteria both have the same
uh both have the same objective now
let's keep going
um so if we if we drill into the
substantial contribution criteria we can
see that there's several different
Clauses here
uh
and
we
want to break this into more manageable
parts so that we can assess our business
by it so what might that look like we we
say this as a clause and then these
Clauses uh may have sub Clauses
um as as these are our lists and and
subless nested lists and they also
reference other pieces of Regulation so
if we go back in and look at uh the the
previous slide you can see
that the regulation is referenced in
here and some of these have sub lists so
um
now we look at the due to significant
harm criteria now these basically are
the criteria that say when doing your
substantial contribution criteria toward
the that main objective you cannot harm
any of the other objectives so this is
what uh it looks like here if we modeled
this as a graph it might look something
like this where uh we have these two
different types of criteria and then we
now are we have these two blue
objectives uh one of them can is
contributing to an objective and the
other one is saying it does not harm the
other objectives we also have Clauses
and then we also can reference other
other things like in this case we're
referencing an appendix but as you can
see the graph is growing and we have
lots of different types
of of nodes and different types of
relationships here
um so what what would that maybe look
like uh this is basically
um an example of what R uh graph for a
single activity it looks like in our
database so this is the actual query
that I used to to find this so we are
just matching on on an activity type
where the name of the activity is the
manufacturer of low carbon Technologies
for transport then we're finding the the
matches we are matching the criteria
and then we are looking for all the
Clause uh children which are these blue
um and uh then we're getting all the
references so this is just what one
specific activity it looks like and
there are
um
107 activities and then those all
reference other regulations and so the
graph actually grows quite a bit
um this is the same the same picture but
with some labels here so as you can see
um the
the
activity starts here and then we've got
the the matches on either side and then
on each one of those the green node is
the substantial contribution criteria
and then the red ones are all the due no
significant harm so we're saying this is
the the main objective and then these
are the all the other objectives that
you can't harm and then they all have
their Clauses which have to be
individually assessed and those on all
the all the yellow are referencing other
regulation which may also be referenced
uh by other activities so
um how do we
um
so how do we use this in Python uh neo4j
actually comes with a python driver
um as you can see in this example
um basically allows you to write Cipher
queries like we saw
um but in in Python strings and then and
then send those as transactions I
actually prefer to use another package
like this called Neo model which as you
can see is doing the same thing but it's
much cleaner and much in my opinion much
easier to read so we can create
structured nodes that have types and
then we can create relationships between
them uh like like this so we've got a
book type an author type and then the
author has uh uh relationship or a book
rather has a relationship to an author
and then on the other side authors have
relationships to books so a book might
only have one author but a uh an author
may have many books
um and then when if you wanted to create
instances of each one of those you can
you can do that like this you can save
the notes give them names and variable
or variable names in in Python and then
you can actually say okay this is a book
type the the book dot author uh connect
that to this author and the neo4j
Neo model package will automatically
create the relationship between there
with whatever the label is specified in
the uh the definition of the type
um now it's time for Q a and I will see
you live
so thank you for the interesting talk
[Applause]
we have some questions
on Slidell so first question is did you
ever have an issue with you thank you
for the interesting talk
okay so sorry did you ever have any
issue with neo4j only allowing for
directed graph we have some questions so
how did you solve
so first question is did you ever have
an issue with you thank you for the
interesting thought
okay stop sorry did you ever have any
issue with Neo or the only allowing for
directed graph we have some questions
so first question is did you ever have
sorry is it working
yes
okay
um did you ever have any issue with
neo4j only allowing for directed graph
I can't hear or see anyone anymore
but
and hear me
allowing for directed graphics
we'll have fun
he can hear as I suppose right I think
for you so he cannot hear anything
so why he cannot hear us
yeah what is the question
there are many is it working
the top ones
sure there are many is it working
hello Marcos we can hear you yeah I will
write down one question so to avoid uh
the echo
okay
uh did you ever have an issue with neo4j
only allowing for people
um
no uh um I'm I'm not sure I I if there's
a follow-up to that question uh I'd love
to hear it but I'll answer how I
understand it
um it allows for directed and undirected
relationships so
um in the example that I uh that I
posted
um of that that query you can either
have uh you basically gonna have an
arrow on on either side of the
relationship
um or no Arrow at all and it will find
any relationship whatever
um there or you could have it
bi-directional as well so uh there is
flexibility there so no you don't it
doesn't have to be directed you have to
be undirected it can be
every relationship is is uh is
independent so you could have some that
are directed and some undirected
um unless you put constraints on it and
force it to
um certain types of relationships to
only be a certainly
uh how do you keep track of data quality
in a graph
um that's a great question it's kind of
one of the things that I
um
was alluding to
in my
um
in one of those bullet points about uh
data management
I think that that's kind of an issue
with every uh every type of database in
big company
um is data management
you can add constraints so you can say
certain types of nodes are required to
have certain properties and you can't
insert them into the database or or
retrieve them without those properties
existing so that's how you can kind of
force to force the schema
um but
um I think documentation and
um
kind of having a team
that that understands the the importance
of of data schema management
um is is uh definitely
not an easy thing to do but it's
definitely necessary
um did you look into Apache age and why
Neo is better than it uh
I did very briefly
um but
uh neo4j I think is probably the most
used uh and most uh
both in terms of just like number of
companies in in businesses using it
um but they also are uh a company that
will give full support
um so we actually
um you know as a startup one of the
things I uh
try not to do is add extra work for our
engineering team if we don't need it so
we use the managed uh neo4j solution
from
um from neo4j
um through gcp
um which takes away some of the overhead
there and that's not that wasn't
something that I could find with with
the Apache solution
um
did you run a hybrid approach or your
company as well and do you make sure
that
um so
right now we we do use a hybrid approach
in terms of like our data storage uh but
not uh at the moment we we're not using
something like a SQL database and a
graph database we're using
um things like cloud storage or or like
S3 buckets um if you're familiar with or
if you're using AWS so that's where we
do like object storage for files and
things like that and then we store the
metadata about it or the references as
an index in the database to say this is
the person who owns this file or this
company owns it or what it's been
attached to
um and then we also use some Vector
embedding
um as well like elasticsearch
um for for some of our machine learning
stuff so we do use a couple different
solutions but
um
the side-by-side SQL and uh graph we we
don't currently use
um if I were to
like if if you were gonna do something
like I described in the talk
um where you had a SQL database and then
you
um
and then you wanted to get extra
insights from it I probably wouldn't or
um I would I would start simple and do
it as kind of like a bad job where
you're you're putting updates in at
regular intervals but not relying on it
as a real-time system
um but if you if it became something
where you needed to make it a real-time
system I would probably use
um like uh
um an event based system and use change
data capture
um on my SQL database and then put the
the changes into the uh the graph
um how do you version your graph
um it's a great question
um
one of the I I kind of
I I probably should have showed that as
uh
you can the there's kind of like two
levels like if you
um if you were gonna like change the
whole data schema that would be like
changing the actual version of your your
um like your data model
um and to keep track of that
um you would do it similarly to how you
do it with like
um in SQL where you probably have like
some type of migration uh scripts or
some type of migration tooling that can
run to kind of like replay the actions
um of changes you've made to your tables
um and and migrating
um data into new tables so you can kind
of have a list of those
um but
um looks like we are out of time and I
appreciate y'all coming I'm sorry I
couldn't be there in person
um but thanks again